le dit ce sont des génies à rester avec
nous que c'est incroyable ce que vous
allez voir sont des génies du calcul
mental
ils n'ont que douze ans il s'appelle
yacine et amine ils sont jumeaux ils
sont cinquièmes ils préparent déjà leur
brevet sa chérie passons aux 5 m et pèse
et dépasse déjà le brevet de troisième
ils ont participé en allemagne à la
junior world cup de calcul mental c'est
la première fois que la france est
qualifiée grâce aux jumeaux ils sont
avec nous ce soir
applaudissements pour yassine
[Applaudissements]
là
et annoncer sous peu un gros bisou ça va
mais shirin vous êtes quand on est un
peu laissé bien des missions d'années
était d'à côté mois la première fois la
donne est venu près de mauvais lait cru
que vous vous êtes habillé pareil
toujours pareil d'accord yacine et amine
vous connaissez ces gens n'ont croisé
tout à l'heure dans les loges ils sont
mignons celui vers moi parce qu'il était
fan c'est pas mal du tout non non non
non c'était pas bon alors les chéris
vous êtes en cinquième et vous avez un
don incroyable pouvez calculer n'importe
quoi on va faire déjà très rapidement
aux petites est donnée - voilà tous très
facile des chiffres très facile comme ça
l'un après l'autre à 10 17 fois urnes
ont dit non à cuba à 10 et à shief quoi
vous donner un chiffre
non mais c'est pas lui tue pas 8 x 8
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui 8 8 8 36 44 lewis hamilton
ban de 90 c'est un truc de malade alors
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit jeu
léché rythme défini près de moi venez là
on voyait qu'on fasse un petit jeu avec
tout le monde
chaque chroniqueur vous allez me
redonner cette fois ci un nombre entre
10 et 99 et je vais rajouter les invités
également d'accord mais mme kennedy lee
c'est bon c'est qu'on va bien chacun
votre tour vous avez vous le donnez moi
je vais le noter sur une calculatrice et
on va voir si vous êtes plus rapide que
la calculette d'accord attention c'est
parti on y va jean-michel 73 53 21 44 70
deux minutes au
17 38 oui 98 oui wendel oui 18 oui kelly
25 combien 475 dawson de 462 alors
maintenant on va faire plus fort des
chiffres vont défiler à toute vitesse
venez à ici sur l'écran d'accord à toute
vitesse
on va en faire des filets vins d'accord
va chiffre s'il vous plaît la caméra
merci on va faire des filets vins
chiffres vous allez devoir les
additionner à toute allure
vous allez essayer également chez vous
faites tous avec le même vécu n'est
qu'une calculette et vous allez voir ils
sont plus rapide encore que la
calculette 20 chiffres vont défiler
vous êtes près des cherry oui attention
c'est parti
alors c'est parti maintenant j'avais
pris 6 rebonds à la nouvelle affiche
5 le résultat
[Applaudissements]
attention bas on va en faire un autre on
va recommencer vous n'avez pas envie de
courir
c'est incroyable moi j'arrive met pas
les voir et franchement essayer chez
vous rien de voir ici c'est incroyable
ça va une vitesse folle comment
commencer vous ça vous est venue parce
qu'on va en faire une deuxième fois
comment ça vous est venu vous vous aider
avec vos parents non sans connaître on
est déjà quand on était petits on aimait
bien les maths et vous aider à vous
aider vous êtes encore petit vous avez
qu à la norme ce qu il me parle vous
avez six mois nous on avait six mois
écoute moi bien je m'en rappelle on se
faisait des rigolades faisait des ronds
ont pesé des propre à toute la journée
les nantais russe tout ça est donc et
vous êtes rendu compte que vous étiez
des sétois c'est votre père qui vous
faisait travailler qui vous faisait des
petits exercices travaille beaucoup de
notre mère il fait quand votre père dans
la vie y'a une base comme un fait mais
j'ai entendu les crs
bien aussi mais voilà contenu émotif
mais voilà au cnrs et votre maman mais
comme on dira c'est plutôt elle qui
s'occupe de vous d'accord d'accord
présent voulais pas en parler
j'ai vu tout à l'heure et c'est un amour
d'ailleurs votre maman je fais un gros
bisou et avoir perçu les amène au
supermarché taille à laquelle je suis
déjà mort combien tu en as dans le
caddie et tout cela est fort utile mais
c'est pas franchement fait mouche avec
vos parents vous prenez des trucs et il
dit voilà on va en avoir maman vont en
avoir pour 80 2 euros 50
c'est ça ou pas superbe arseus éclata je
vais essayer de faire l'exercice que
vous faites avec laquelle que déjà petit
exercice comme ça si je vous dis par
exemple 9 / 13 9 / 13 tu dis coulisses
combien vous dites 6 donc 0,6 soit 9,2
non 3 à 0
c'est même temps c
9 2 4 non c'est pas grave je le tarn
[Applaudissements]
alors
j'ai un petit coup de chiffres là comme
ça si vous nous rejoignez on est en
direct et ses deux garçons
c'est incroyable ce qu'ils arrivent à
faire moi je suis fan si l'on fait un
test de qi bah ouais ce que vous avez
fait un test de quilles à signer yamin
oui et alors combien 125 c'est deux fois
plus que nous à l'orage les deux le même
accueil ils avaient tous les deux le
même qi ouais ouais merde comme ils vont
sauter une classe et alors vous n'avez
pas souhaité classe maintenant ont
préféré passer le brevet accord oui déjà
125 130 c'est moins de 5% de la
population faut savoir mais ce qui est
très étonnant c'est même quand par
hasard une toute petite erreur sur la
xxi mxn 8e virgule vous répondez
toujours en même temps additionnel il me
fait la même erreur en droit c'est vrai
c'est quoi c'est comment c'est possible
et on n'est pas jumeaux pour rien
et
on va parler comme ça le dernier qui
vous a parlé comme ça c'est emmanuel
macron du président obama on va faire un
petit coup là comme ça de barco parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de rois réaction 1 sur
twitter hashtag balances ton post dites
nous ce que vous en pensez
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voulaient ce
qu'on peut refaire le truc avec sa
lancer le débat je vais essayer de faire
un truc quoi dit que là-bas excusez-moi
need love hashtag dit loeb je vais
essayer de le faire moi avec la
calculette d'accord attention si vous
mettez toujours le décompte en région un
chiffre doit donc d'abord hier des
comptes
oui je bosse il est urgent suis très bon
en lettres ce à quoi j'ai décroché et
j'ai décroché 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g yacine et amine est ce que moi ce
qu'on peut pas faire d'un petit dernier
ça je peux faire sa vie malgré ces
thèmes et les enfants vous avez combien
moyenne en maths
vous êtes en cinquième voilà bah 18,3
sur ma c'est étonnant c'est tout
n'aurait franchement vous avez combien
pour matt enfin alors us ou 12 au bout
c'est en héros gif a non mais j'avais un
bleu v14 je travaille régulièrement vous
ouais pareil 10 11 10 11
ah ouais ouais grave manger boire et
vous fait pas la cinquième non tu
passais jours donnez votre date de
naissance au petit alors ma date de
naissance
on va donner la date de naissance de
khellili 690 à bayonne jour ses lundis
mardis nouvelle bien on va dire qu'elle
joue 27/03 1990 de dieu
90 27 03 90 ils vont donner le jour
données sur les locales et leurs noms
mais 27 mars 90 kelly est née quelques
jours vous avez une chance sur cette
laid mais qui perdure quand un bélier
ouais je dis lentilles et toi dès ce
lundi
ouais mais ça général adjoint louis
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut faire est ce qu'on
peut se faire un dernier truc est
beaucoup plus dur avec le barca ou
encore une fois regardez attention ça va
défiler essayer chez vous une dernière
fois à troyes 2-1 les bleus comptent que
3 des ventes saas et leur porter très
bien faire il ya pas l'air j'adore sa
centrale à l'arrêt
là franchement c'est incroyable
incroyable qu'est ce qu'on peut faire un
petit truc
ils ont peut-être eu quatre années alors
allez-y vous allez me dire un truc en
fait avec la calculatrice
voilà vous allez prendre un nombre entre
guise et 99 10 et 99 ans et vous allez
le multiplier trois fois ça veut dire
par exemple 93 93 4 fois d'être atteint
je vous demande après vous vous nous
aimez des méchants
donc je fais 93 93 93
et vous vous dites là et nous on vous
dira
[Musique]
et j'ai 15 ans de bêtises et 1
alors donc je vais boire chiffres et je
vais tout vous dire le résultat jeudi
par 3,3 fois au cube sur la tête de ma
mère j'ai un peu sonné ton contrôle moi
j'ai l'impression que j'ai prendre douze
heures de colle nations grâce à mon père
ça fait six ans ça fait quel ça fait 16
ans j'ai pas taper sur une calculatrice
[Applaudissements]
qui juge et non frères en plus je le
faisais même pas en avant pour sûr je
passe pas j'ai vraiment travaillé dans
le tissu mais ouais et donc voilà donc
et au liban voilà donc que là on peut
prendre ce poste ça se passe pas alors
attention je vais le faire d'accord
entre 1,99 de danton qui voit par dix
d'ici quatre ans je n'ai pas prendre fin
que je vous prenez pour un con faut le
dire tout de suite
[Rires]
ok
voyez le résultat alors le résultat que
j'ai obtenu ses 175 1616
c'est comme ça continue on va le refaire
mais c'était bien ça c'est 56 open et à
[Applaudissements]
regarder
je vais leur faire attention regardez
et
alors si je vous dis 912 1673 87
alors
est ce que vous voulez est ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse un dernier petit
rhume mais je sais que plein de gens qui
réagissent ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens
devant la télé qui nous regarde là ce
soir je vous le dis et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se disent c'est incroyable
franchement je suis fan doux
j'aurais aimé être un de vous deux je
vous jure
alors oui on peut faire une grosse
publication aux multiplications peut
faire quoi
alors ils sont pas là c'est pas des
boîtes de foie gras castaldi quoi je
crois l'anniversaire de santé alors
alors non alors alors oui qu'est ce que
c'est que ça prouve ma maindru alors je
sais pas pourquoi il m'emmène à paper
board un dans 25 ans c'est à dire alors
on me dit vous pouvez calculer cinq
chiffres par cinq chiffres c'est quoi ça
donc ça veut dire que vous avez votre
seul chiffre
vous avez multiplié par d'autres est
élevé et les mettre directement
il va mettre que leur poser c'est ouf
alors je dois faire
[Applaudissements]
ça ici je suis en hochant sueur ça
aurait volé 5 x 5 philippe guionie la
séquence
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il parlait d'esprit de john eales
d'accord nous lie c'est un moment et un
truc qui soit en dessous attention
bonnes bases donc là donc là je fais je
vais 5 6 x 5 x 5 6 voilà alors attends
donc je fais pareil 11,5 fois non
on ne parlera à côté de l'autre côté
l'autre ont été dictées si tu me reste
cinq ans nous en donne un chèque
d'ailleurs bien à un nombre à cinq
filles voilà encore 56 appliquez-vous un
peu pour l'écriture s'il vous plaît
voilà vous avez deux minutes n'ont il
est vrai pas vous a fait en bas coûts
soutenue alors à la faute reviennent je
prends ma calculette quand même et il
pose même pas à pas je vais faire le
calcul moi je vois le temps de me sera
peut-être devenir un c
bravo les mecs tu en as perdu ta
ça ne m'a pas mal de résultats moi j'ai
fait plus vite qu'on met une heure le
problème un homme moyen c'est-à-dire pas
comme nous au dessus de 12 6 me les
bananes flambées normal il met 5 à 6
minutes pour résoudre ce genre de
multiples occasions et nous écrit les
bananes comme nous on mettrait à 14
minutes voire 13 à 14h groupe
et il y en a qui bossent à lehman anglo
american qui tue pas calculé par rhodia
15 mai sur dix est dramatique
[Applaudissements]
mais vous le débat tous les cours en
face parce que là je vous dis on a une
petite erreur sur le début parce que
c'est bien 6-3 5-5
ces quatre là les mecs alors on leur
fait moi je savais que tu veux le faire
les mecs rocade
tu savais qu'elle est européenne non
mais tu as été très fort puisque le
pense qu'on l'a on la déconcentrer on a
beau parler là on va le faire dans le
silence quand même en combien de temps
vous pouvez résoudre cette
multiplication à cinq chiffres d'après
minutes à peu près de midi on va
chronométrés entre 2008 et 2008 à
ancoisne
[Rires]
l'armée ajouté moi j'ai des chiffres qui
tombent tous les quarts d'heure si on
commence à changer concept toutes les
cinq minutes je vais arrêter un alors je
vais le faire donc je pose un truc je
vais pas tu retiens qu'alors je vous le
dis bien sûr c'est pas du tout truqués
rhinois n'en aurait rien du tout même
truqués deux façons comme on voulait
contre ux aix les bains en quelques
lettres et sauver moins de temps on fait
mumuse dedans il n'a y pas les shebab
ont ces gens ont si peu avant dans la
love room à vous faire d'ailleurs des
chocolats merci à vous c'est à dire est
que l'ajout doigt c'est important merci
à eux et donc je vais refaire là je me
refaire la multiplication vous allez
avoir une minute hockey est quoi le
minutes pile une à deux millions une
minute
allez on se met d'accord tu tu aurais
minutes 45 min 45 et 54 me disant c'est
fait bondues s'est vendu la photo
merci alors attention je change les
chiffres que vous êtes prêts mais écrit
mieux tes chiffres
audi donc toi ô vous les décrire allez-y
championne mal à s'extirper des alizés
kimberley dans les marseillais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lui tu me parlais dans les parties non
allez-y kinda kimber lui passer un coup
elle écrit bien déjà décrit mieux
fois les matelas oui fayyad est crade
mais c'est bon ben c'est vous a plu aux
kimberley comment ça me paraît avoir
tourné dans les faits si bon c'est pas
mais à la première n'a pas l'air commode
maintenant sur égal à égal dans les cas
il faut mettre égal mais un trait entrée
au sujet de sa mégane et scénic il
serait triple saut comme cela on aurait
très bien pu leur faire baisser pour
qu'il s'habitue et de calmer votre mec
qui finalement est vraiment d'accord
alors je mets le végal leur attention
est ce que agatha la productrice est ce
qu'on est capable de mettre un chrono
d'une minute 45 tout à fait des prêts
bravo agatha exceptionnelle alors
attention
3 2 1 c'est parti
sachez qu'un homme normal mais six
minutes pour le faire et encore et
encore roche lâché laisse tranquille je
laisse tranquille il faut les laisser
bosser
il ya des gens qui sont en train de
bosser 1 ils sont en train de calculer
vous allez voir c'est d'ailleurs je veux
faire laquelle plus qu'est ce qu'on a
cette claque tac tac tac tac deux plus
rapides comme ça je laisse les mecs que
les lots radio pas de l'être et la de
fort hood est là et il vous reste qu'une
minute 02 sais pas si je n'avais pas
parce que vous faites genre et voir la
fin je viens d'avoir la faux alors
attention la spécialiste mathématiques a
parlé vous avez le temps auparavant des
spécialistes arithmétique voie lactée le
relais des marchés hier ouais du ps que
johnny la réponse stop attendait les
mecs je vous avais fait tjrs un ace
alors jeu on va vérifier ensemble je
vais être ensemble je ne vous dis pas si
c'est bon si c'est mauvais d'accord
d'accord avec suspense je regarde ces
inquié chis at12 ac 1-2 vous voulez je
marque on n'est pas loin tout ça c'est
un 2 1 le 6 c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
confiserie ya non pas nous ne faisons
pas de confiseries les crêpes au sucre
c'est à côté
merci alors le si c'est bon le 2 c'est
bon le un bon le 5
c'est bon le zéro c'est bon aïe aïe aïe
la 8c bon le 4 c'est bon le 8 c'est bon
et là il ya ces deux et se moque de la
qui me dérange que moi je suis à 17 sur
laquelle tu as alors où ces messieurs
bons samaritains 7 vaut mieux pourquoi
il ya une semaine de l'un aucune idée a
donc c'est pas fait le reste est bon on
va dire si la calculette qui a fait une
erreur
bien sûr parce que ça c'est extrêmement
dur est ce que la dernière fois
franchement est-ce le wiki leur façon
[Musique]
on fait un écran d'abord et après on
verra mais ça et on se tait pendant une
minute vingt jeunes qui revenaient aux
chauvauds le silence complet c'est vous
qui parlez 23 minutes 45 secondes tu
veux une minute jordan c'est toi qui vas
dire eh oui non si toi tu es là je peux
vous dire on fait un petit jeu et je
vous ai demandé le cadeau rêvé toi c'est
quoi ton cadeau raid et une trottinette
électrique une routine est électrique
moi ce que je peux faire
oui j'ai des gg de trois contacts et
doit une console de jeu et une
trottinette électrique
le défi semble déjà on va se refaire un
petit trading je vous fais défiler les
chiffres ont mené l'équipe à la fin ça
sans titre et disputera la dernière
épreuve bon humide c'est parti on fait
tout ça pour au bout de souffle yacine
et amine sont deux coups
regardez
maman sans gaz
[Applaudissements]
ça fait rien
allez c'est bon c'est pas la peine de
mettre la musique tout ça c'est des
cacahuètes c'est l'apéritif échoué mais
maintenant on va faire le défi pour
gagner la trottinette électrique et la
console de jeu attendez vous à le faire
ensemble quelque chose oui question
quand même c'est que c'est bizarre parce
que tokyo ne quelques gâteries c'est
normal que tu arrives dit vous voulez
vous mais si tu le faisais mes que un
crayon à papier comme dans
le gafi avec je suis pas stéphanois mais
je vous le dis faites gaffe les cas de
rupture le fait de faire des sandwiches
on va dormir là on le fait en groupe je
crois que s'il y aura les chroniqueurs
que pourrait le faire aussi non le temps
froid après les perdants alors attention
c'est parti si vous nous rejoignez je
vais mettre cinq chiffres multipliés par
cinq autres chiffres on aura une minute
compte
l'accord pour le son doyen s'il fait
vous le faites tous les we en fait enfin
on se concerte d'accord sur tout
attention vous n'avez pas de bruit pas
de bruit voilà celui qui fait un bruit
je le sors et je l'amène chez la
conseillère au fond c'est parti assez
tôt mais on peut avoir un crayon qui
narre sachets arturia ça je me suis moi
tunisien sans merci le change de
feuilles jeu lagarde et hans zimmer à
chaque fois elle servira ce mouchoir à
gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
consonne voyelle
on a dit du calme à rabat de l'ormeau à
face au fond de la classe fans quelle
écriture de bouffon c'est la dernière
sur une écriture d'autistes way
l'inquiète sur d'autres îles et les
cultures d'autisme et vous reconnaîtrai
ma signature sur le licenciement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mettront pas le tableau la poussée vous
aussi on fait attention et petits traits
caramel 30
j'avais une minute trente yacine et amis
je vous laisse sans attention c'est
parti
une 1030 tu veux faire de mon côté mois
allez-y comme auxerre l'art déchire un
accord ait un petit parti
je sais mais ce
c'est énorme
c'est tout
4 s'est trompé
merci
je
monsieur bouchard une lettre va mieux
j'avais pirates 1703 il nous reste trois
oui et ne pressions pas
tous
c'est bien de 4,6
c'est épuisant j'ai jamais eu un plateau
aussi talbot
il reste 13 secondes
shu
on laisse 15 secondes on laisse 15
secondes en plus un tour là quand même
oui 15 c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
attention on va le faire ensemble
si vous avez bon vous repartirez avec un
vélo une trottinette électrique
électrique
j'ai voulu tu voues langouet cette
protéine est comme ça et toi il se
console de jeux attention il faut en
moyenne 6 à 7 minutes - de même plus un
mois je vous dis moi je mets 25 minutes
pour le faire alors attention le 8 c'est
bon le 4e bon c'est bon le ciss c'est
bon le 3 c'est bon le 7 c'est bon le 7
c'est encore bon le 8 c'est bon et vous
terminez par koala à 3 333 g13 en voilà
d'abord des choses
[Applaudissements]